and then communicating well because when
I went from the 67 who knew me and knew
where I was coming from and then I had
to go to another level how was I going
to keep that same Communications that
same idea of meritocracy that's why I
started to write down principles okay so
I'm having to make
decisions well I wanted everybody to be
in it with me so I've by doing the
videos and taping everything so
everybody body could see then they could
see what's being made and so that helped
the idea of meritocracy and then you
write it down uh one of the uh
challenges that I found is to be totally
straightforward with
people that was one of the best things
about your book was how direct you are
and um how you talked about you know
leaving your ego at the door giving
honest feedback constructive criticism
not being offended by really something
that's trying to help you you and being
able to accept in our case being able to
accept coaching being able to accept um
instruction and then taking positive
action to improve it um that's a big
part of our culture but the way you
articulated in the book was was
fantastic and um it really showed a you
know a very a strong commitment to that
that's obvious in brid of water you do a
lot of
that